variant is set to spread much easier and
many cases are reportedly pretty mild
though still some are worried it could
impact the local convention industry
madison kimbrough heard from local
vendors tonight and has this report
madison
yeah we reached out to lbcva and so far
no shows have been canceled as you can
see we're right in front of the
convention center but some vendors we
spoke to say other venues are now
rescheduling as this new variant comes
into play
i was going to be a part of different
bridal expos and those got moved again
so i definitely think that it hasn't
recovered as much as
it seems vendors and freelance artists
like justine are seeing an increase in
events being canceled and or rescheduled
and many think it's due to the omicron
variant i feel like i got an email a
couple days ago that was saying
something was moved again and then
another one was cancelled um so
i've been trying to get out there in
market
in the convention space while no shows
at the convention center have been
canceled thus far in a statement lvcva
said we will continue to follow our gold
standard protocols that have been in
place since we reopened the las vegas
convention center back in june as for
one of the biggest shows coming up that
would be the ces trade show and
according to its site organizers say
it's too early to determine the impact
of this latest variant we will monitor
and adjust plans and health protocols as
necessary colineet atiya owner of a to z
events here in las vegas says although
this new variant may pose a threat to
her business she isn't worried we have
been working with the convention and
events industry for the past 20 years
i'm so secure about the future that i'm
actually hiring people now
and ces the consumer electronics show
takes place on january 5th that's going
to last until the 8th reporting live in
front of the convention center madison
kimbrough live local now madison thank
you a delay now in the